and joining us now with more on a top
story is the president's former attorney
John Dowd all also the author of the
introduction to the Muller report
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
mister down counselor I'll ask you I'm I
wouldn't want my words twisted like that
especially considering what you said was
perfectly ethical legal and honestly the
right thing to do as you had a joint
defense leading up to that point well I
had an obligation as counsel to the
president to to find out what was going
on and I'm so glad judge Sullivan
ordered the transcript because we now
know the truth and we also know that
this this entire report by Muller is a
fraud and we're going to find more of
these things isn't it ironic that this
man who kept in dieting and prosecuting
people for process crimes committed a
false statement in his own report by by
taking out half my words they changed
the akai the tenor and the contents of
that conversation with Robert Keller and
it's an outrage
and there's probably more of it you know
and to this professor Dershowitz that in
and of itself is is an outrage because
you're literally changing the exact
meaning of what the counselor said
number one number two how embarrassing
for Muller last week to say oh I
couldn't indict on obstruction because
of a Department of Justice rule that
that doesn't allow or questions the
ability of of him to to make a
determination as it relates to whether
you can can or cannot indict a sitting
president and then you look at the team
that he put around them with Andrew
Weissman and company all chronicled in
Sidney Powell's license to lie and
professor you care about civil liberties
I care about civil liberties this is
every American needs to be concerned in
all this this is a very very serious
issue the distortion of the doubt quote
is very serious specially since remember
that a rope
court by a special counsel is always
going to be one-sided therefore you have
to trust it because the other side
doesn't have a chance to look at it and
show what's wrong with it the way it
would in an adversarial situation if a
lawyer made a representation like that
to a court and said this is the quote
and left out the crucial context which
showed as John said that what he
discussed was not only absolutely proper
but obligatory for a counsel when you
have a joint defense agreement to find
out exactly what's likely to be used
against your your client this is nothing
first nothing inappropriate we have to
find he said that who wrote that
paragraph who wrote that paragraph I
have a Gaddis crucial how did it go how
did it get passed Muller why was it
included in there remember right from
the beginning I said before this report
is made public it should be given to the
defense and including the former defense
attorney like John down to be able to go
through it with a fine-tooth comb find
problems with it
file a report stating the defendants
position at the same time so the
American public can judge which is more
credible this way it just turns out once
they ask you this and it turns out it's
totally distorted when it doesn't we
don't have the FBI professor giving
special treatment to Hillary Clinton in
her investigation won the exoneration
written before anybody's even
interviewed that that never happens
allowing other people including a
witness inside the room while she is
being questioned by the FBI thirdly they
don't record it they don't have the 302s
they brag about it
struck in Page brag about Loretta
Lynch's role and that there was no way
there that they were not going to rig
that investigation I know you like the
Clintons but I think you like the
Constitution the rule of law equal
justice an application of our laws more
look I like I like to make sure that
we're not weaponizing our criminal
justice system I think we have to use
the criminal justice system only in
extreme cases we had here an
investigation it may not have been the
perfect investigation
but James Comey concluded and the
Justice Department concluded you
acknowledge everybody else that he had
done something wrong well if you're the
Secretary of State and previous
secretaries of state used home personal
personal emails then you have to ask
yourself was there any precedent for
this kind of prosecution so I'm
satisfied that there was no prosecution
of Hillary Clinton I'm not satisfied
with the way in which they've gone after
Donald Trump I think equal protection of
the law requires less Commission not
more criminalization John Dowd last few
words you last shot Shawn Shawn Shawn
yes sir not only went after Donald Trump
they went after it they went after his
lawyers I mean that paragraph that they
put out and therefore he's a smear of me
and my reputation and when I used to be
a prosecutor if anyone made an
allegation about a lawyer and what he
was doing its outright what he was
crossing the line
I thought well why would you talk to I
met with well I met with I met with
baller and Quarles the whole time they
never said a word to me
and stuck that state's ambles up a
little in their report all right I'm up
on a heart break guys thank you both
very important analysis